- I showed the movie at my
house there the other week
and my boys, and my stock with my boys
and all their friends just went way up.
- [Kelly Clarkson] It's
like the first time
you've done something amazing for them.
- Truly.
(kelly and dwayne laughing)
They were just so blown away.
- [Dwayne Johnson] That's
so funny, not Bond-
- No.
- [Kelly] Not The Thomas Crown Affair.
None of the things, yeah.
(laughing)
- Well done Pierce, you
finally got there, buddy.
(laughter)
- I could see their faces just beaming
with joy for me and for the whole movie.
They just loved it.
- Well wait, let's talk
about Dr. Fate for a minute
because what I found
amazing is the whole time,
I kept going, how does one
see when that's your costume?
Like here, your costume has no-
- You don't see anything.
- [Kelly] You have no eyes.
Is it really- you don't see?
- No, it's just like putting
a bucket on your head
for heaven's sake.
(laughter)
I mean, it looks gorgeous and I did,
I mean...
(guests laughing)
- He can't see!
Like, lucky you don't like suffer
from claustrophobia or anything like that.
- No, but well those two helmets,
the kind of ornate, beautiful
helmet that I carry.
And then there's this large
bucket helmet that I would put
on my head.
Very briefly, because I
couldn't see anything.
I put it on.
- [Kelly] Oh my God
(guests laughing)
- It's ridiculous. There was a point
in the movie where I transform
and it's this kind of conduct
and I have to reach down and get this bag.
So, action, put it on and it's...
(laughter)
sorry, sorry, let's do it again.
- I love that it was
like you're Doctor Fate
and I guess fate is in
someone else's hands,
'cause you can't see.
I was like, it was amazing.